[Music]
we're gonna need a bigger slingshot Fred
we've discovered a third island we need
to put aside our differences and work
together safe from being destroyed what
we really need is a hero actually that
positions been filled
I have to get a team together we're
busting you out she's super smart wait
who's that and why is she all over these
achievement award I just don't think
this is gonna work okay so one usually
angry walk to herself
left-handed probably with fun being
alone
look Decker okay guys
step 1 travel undetected to the island
pull the gadgets you'll see here have
been designed with your current mission
in mind the first Bing and visit spread
how long does the invisibility last for
forever
what Chiba we're not gonna be able to
see each other okay so what's the plan
trust me I know working with what we get
we're gonna need a disguise
goodness crazy what's going on down
there
Piggy's challenging is 12 breakdance
battle
[Music]
oh it's on Wow love it too I don't know
if I'm gonna fit in your back anyone
smell bacon
hello I know we've had our differences
in peace I don't want to see your face
any more than you want to see mine
we're all in danger you know we have a
truth this is not how a truce were just
say what you gotta say red we've
discovered that there's a third island
and they're plotting to destroy us all
Bird Island give me one good reason why
I should believe you
I'll show you the proof will team say oh
you know this guy this is one of my best
buddies red and these are the guys hi
we're the guys guys this is silver oh
wow it is such a pleasure to meet not
you but you may I shake your hose
thank you so I I hear you're some kind
of engineering wizard or whatever oh I
mean I don't like to brag but wait who
is that and why is she all over this
achievement award
it's amazing right each of you has been
selected because you're the best in your
field that we could find Oh
your skills will be put to the test
facing this as you can clearly see this
is a volcano volcano is what my
assistant was going to say cystic normal
actually
it's a composite volcano you can tell by
the height and the clearly apparent bed
clusters okay forget I said okay no this
is a it's a superweapon
Oh weird it looks just like a volcano
yep and here's the scary part
this is their psychotic leader oh how
they get in there or hey I mean you took
up Pam this is they're psychotic leader
ah whoa whoa hey buddy do you know her
what me no no definitely not absolutely
not never seen her before in my life who
is that I don't know not terribly
convincing welcome to my piggy gadget
lab oh yeah all of the gadgets have been
designed specifically with your current
mission in mind the first Bing and
visits pray need to go undetected in
playing sunt and this phrase does
exactly that
whoa whoa indeed that's amazing how long
does the invisibility last for forever
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay gang step one we're gonna break in
and deactivate the weapon we look
amazing
alright you get started on the lockdown
sequence I'm gonna hit the John
yes sir we gotta get that key card okay
Courtney get that card there's something
in the way Jack what's going on down
there
there's something fighter the way
ah maybe it's on the other side okay
hold on pretend baby
[Music]
Chuck get that card
[Music]
yeah I'm just gonna there are any good
mother day songs okay for Mother's Day
Mother's Day we go to brunch Mother's
Day nope I'm not going to go out for
bridge
[Music]
[Music]
oh no it's mom II did it I love you
mommy
in honor of Father's Day we're gonna
spend the day without daddy doing all
the things he likes to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
- you're so boring we should just make
him a card
[Music]
[Music]
hey it's me red you know the guy
everybody hated who kind of saved the
whole island anyway
war with Leonard in the pigs what are
you gonna do I'm a foodie still going on
those what and BOM and Chuck are doing
whatever they do I eat dirt and me well
I still have some anger issues but I'm
finding healthier ways to deal with it
Fred I know we've had our differences
but we've discovered that there's a
third eyelid
in their bodies you destroy yourself
maybe one good reason why I should
believe you now show you the proof will
teams really but this is a hundred times
I have to get a team together guys this
is my sister silver I just don't think
you're gonna be compatible with the team
oh wow it is such a pleasure to meet not
you but you I like her we gotta get to
the island is what my assistant was
going to say
[Music]
this is the amazing team I've been
working around the clock for well that's
disappointing what we're gonna break in
and deactivate the weapon was amazing we
gotta get that key card
Oh Oh fellow
Eagle God how he's doing a voice yeah
I'm just gonna
[Music]